So now that I can create a complex composition of parallel nested with parallelism,
taking in my audio stream, putting it through a sequence of operations,
coming out with a re-normalized stream like this,
it opens the door to something called task parallelism.
Now, task parallelism is where you run multiple independent tasks,
more or less like separate programs each working on their own data.
So you've probably noticed that the nested problem that we looked at before,
the volume normalizer, could be launched from the CPU, but the GPU's really good at running lots of things at once,
so we can take our volume normalization algorithm,
and we can run it on dozens of audio streams all at the same time.
We've got one program with multiple instances handling multiple audio streams
all at the same time on a single GPU without any complicated CPU to GPU communication.
This is task parallelism, and this is one way to get a lot of power out of the GPU all at once.